[Música]
la naturaleza hasta donde alcanza la
vista esto es en el sur de inglaterra
lejos de las ciudades y pueblos y lleno
de animales que vagan libremente este es
el aspecto de esta zona hace dos décadas
los campos de trigo y los años de
cultivo intensivo
[Música]
toda esta tierra por aquí era cultivable
lo que dio lugar al cultivo de cereales
trigo y cebada en 2004 charly burel fue
el primer agricultor de reino unido en
renunciar a sus tierras de labranza y
convertir toda la zona en una reserva de
animales y zona de conservación uno de
los motivos para hacerlo fue el dinero
perdíamos dinero por el tipo de suelo
que teníamos arcilla muy pesada y húmeda
y pensamos y si cortamos la última
cosecha y vemos lo que surge
con la ayuda de un biólogo optó por
reintroducir especies olvidadas cerdos
de raza tan words
y cigüeñas blancas
el año pasado una de nuestras hembras se
apareó con un macho salvaje y tuvimos
los primeros polluelos en reino unido-
desde hace más de 600 años
todas estas especies sirven para crear
un mejor hábitat para los insectos y las
aves y hasta ahora está funcionando
con el paso del tiempo esta zona se
llenó de vida con la fauna
[Aplausos]
el cerdo abre el suelo la semilla de
sauce acá en mayo en estos terrenos
abiertos y la malva en la planta que
alimenta a la mariposa tornasolada y a
la vez el cerdo produce el hábitat para
la mariposa por eso tenemos la mayor
población de mariposas este nuevo
ecosistema también ha traído a muchos
visitantes se ha movido mucho
no mucho no tal vez una vez a la semana
en el último par de meses así que sí con
bastante regularidad y aquí viene la
cerda gracias al ecoturismo y a la venta
de carne ni wiland es rentable ahora el
proyecto ha animado a otros a emprender
iniciativas similares como aquí en
escocia durante 800 años subo ovejas
pastando en estos campus esa época ha
terminado
una parte de la zona se ha convertido en
un criadero de castores
los castores vinieron aquí y
construyeron represas
bajar
para financiar el proyecto la pareja
construyó cabañas
casi tan sencillas y rústicas como el
entorno
este es uno de nuestros alquileres de
vacaciones se llama el escondite los
castores hicieron la cama la cama está
hecha de madera cortada por los castores
cuesta cien euros la noche para
disfrutar del silencio y de una vista
única todos estos pequeños y
extraordinarios canales y estanques
árboles muertos para ser exactos y los
árboles muertos son realmente muy
hermosos pero también muy importantes
para la biodiversidad los castores
fueron sólo el primer paso muy pronto se
reintroducirán aquí más especies escocia
es de hecho una de las peores zonas de
gran bretaña donde nuestra biodiversidad
está tan golpeada por el uso humano de
la tierra que algunas de las que solían
ser nuestras especies más comunes están
ahora al borde de la extinción y
entonces realmente es una emergencia
tenemos que hacer algo serio y por eso
estamos haciendo esto los estudios
muestran que volver las zonas a su
estado salvaje puede tener efectos
beneficiosos para todo el ecosistema e
incluso podría tener un efecto positivo
en el cambio climático